regarder la quatrième saison de gomorrhe est
un ordre la scène de la mort de cyrus est
était une scène très difficile parce que
c'est un métier où très souvent
mélange de profession et de vie
entrelacs était une scène c'est
la finale de la troisième saison de
gomorrhe très intense pour nous acteurs et
pour les deux personnages
nous avons passé quatre ans ensemble
sur ce projet et c'était donc
assez fort et sacrifier cela
facile pour jenny frappé tellement aussi
nous comme les acteurs de l'autre était
très sympa car à mon avis c'en est un
des plus belles scènes de la série dans lesquelles
enfin ces deux personnages s'ouvrent
les robinets de l'émotivité et puis c'était
amusant de voir les réactions qui
ils sont venus plus tard car à un an et
milieu de cette scène il y a un
bombardements continus et la question que
nous est soumis plus fréquemment est
le même à n'importe quelle latitude de
De la France à l'Angleterre à l'Allemagne
italie ma ciro est yen sel e
il faudra attendre pour voir le quatrième
saison de gomorrhe pour savoir si ciro
c'est vivant alors beaucoup
la première chose est londres qui sera là
emplacement d'un épisode du quatrième
épisode de la quatrième saison qui
nous comprendrons dans un sens comment
il existe une dynamique criminelle répandue dans le
monde mais surtout maintenant ils sont largement répandus
même au sein de la finance
mondial
la deuxième chose est qu'il y a une place dans
province de Naples
encore jamais exploré où cela nous mènera
la quatrième saison qui se situe dans un
campagne désolée où il y a un immense
villa qui nous ferait peut-être penser à
une famille paysanne
pourtant dans ce lieu bucolique naturel
exposé au beau temps il se présente comme
de la terre une famille incroyablement
mal que vous saurez bientôt
l'introduction de cette nouvelle famille
qui sont dits pertinents ils sont
parents éloignés de gènes dont celui dont
les gènes devront restaurer le
paix la troisième chose que je pense ce
surtout cette saison jamais comme avant
rien ne sera comme toujours est la production
dit que dans le processus de traitement d'un
cinquième écriture il faudra voir qui est là
sera
ont annoncé une cinquième saison lo
Riccardo Tozzi a fait que le
président de cattleya la maison de
production qui est la mère de la gomorrhe
ce sont eux qui décident évidemment
le destin nous attend ici
Nous voyons
profitons de la sortie de ce quatrième e
puis
[Musique]